I found that people were falling into a
trap when it came to anything involving
statistics there was a reflexive
skepticism you can prove anything with
Statistics or this famous book how to
lie with Statistics and just this idea
that you seem kind of really clever if
you say oh well yeah you can prove
anything with it with Statistics but if
you're basically just rejecting
everything on the grounds that it's got
statistics in well that's not smart
either
Tim Harford welcome to the show all
right it's great to join you what would
you say your area of expertise is seems
like a relatively diverse background
yeah that's a good question I'd say I'm
a professional nerd does that help I
mean I trained as an economist actually
also as a philosopher but that sounds
slightly pretentious so let's just say I
tried as an economist and then after a
few other Adventures became a writer in
print
books Financial Times column so you're
obviously writing about economics and
then began a radio for BBC Radio 4
program about statistics and so I had to
learn pretty quickly about statistics
and over time it's just got more and
more
uh into anything that's interesting in
social science behavioral economics
psychology economics statistics data
data visualization and along all of that
I've become very very interested in
stories which which I explore in my
cautionary tales podcast and and all my
books what's the single thread that's
tying all of that together
I think the single thread is I'm
fascinated by evidence-based ideas
and I just love telling people about
those ideas and and telling I'm not I'm
not so much in the self-help like here's
how to use these ideas to make make a
million dollars or whatever I'm like I
have to tell you a story about this time
that this thing happened and what this
teaches us about
whatever game theory loss aversion
whatever it is uh so yeah nerd stories
did you read Seth Stevens davidowitz's
uh don't trust your gut earlier this
year
I skimmed it I enjoyed the his first one
which was what everybody lies yes I got
I got more out of everybody lives I
think possibly because he was
coming at questions that I've been
thinking about for a very very long time
in don't trust your gut so I was like oh
this is great but I know this stuff but
everybody lies I thought was really
interesting that
uh that kind of
Insight that what people type into
Facebook and what people type into
Google
are different and what people type into
Google tells you what they really want
to know and what people type into
Facebook because it was Facebook at the
time tells you about the way they're
trying to present themselves to the
world and that just from that very
simple Insight that I think so much came
out
for the people that haven't read
Stephen's first book there's a great
example where he looks at the most
common my boyfriend is sentences and he
Compares what it is on Facebook and what
it is on Google and on Facebook it's
things like my boyfriend is so loving
the best caring so on and so forth uh my
boyfriend is on Google is my boyfriend
is not having sex with me my boyfriend
is having an affair how can I tell my
boyfriend is falling out of love with me
and uh yeah I mean sometimes Google we
tell Google things that we don't even
tell ourselves you know we just decide
to type something in to check it out and
it's maybe
something that we don't want to say
internally too much but yeah I mean the
the the uh stated and revealed
preferences
is something that I've been increasingly
fascinated with recently have you looked
at that much at all well I mean it's
like That's a classic thing in economics
and an economist I think historically
have been too
too uninterested in stated preferences
we basically said well we don't we don't
take people seriously at all we only
look at what they do
so people can say they want something
but it doesn't matter look at what they
actually do and that is the real guide
to their preferences and I think
behavioral economics has has given us a
slightly richer lens to think about that
um but I mean that that fundamental
distrust of cheap talk I think
yeah it's it's still a useful insight
yeah you're having skin in the game I
think is a generally a good heuristic
for everybody to assess what's going on
with I know that you're a fan of Rory
Sutherland as well and um his most
recent book when he was talking about
transport for humans uh and some of the
challenges great books great book so
fantastic
um yeah and yeah I think some of the
relatively cheap but incredibly
effective signals there that uh
companies can do because it's not just
interactions between humans right it's
interactions between Brands between
experiences what was that thing you
wrote a blog post about being delayed on
the channel tunnel yeah it was on the on
the Eurostar so all it was a financial
times column but all my ft columns after
a month get put on my website Tim
harford.com so you know as long as
you're willing to wait you can read them
you don't have to subscribe although you
should subscribe because the ft is the
best paper in the world but the Eurostar
basically it's the usual kind of story
are massive cues and no one would tell
us what was going on and we were all
standing around everyone's super
stressed and it's 30 degree heat which I
know is 85 90 degrees in in Fahrenheit
and you know and so on and so on and we
missed the train and we still knew
nobody knew what was going on and the
point that I made is I actually wrote
that column in an hour
on the train
while a trade was still stationary
but the point was I was it was air
conditioned I was sitting down I had
power I had space and I knew that I knew
we'd get to London eventually
and so it's one thing to have a delay
but the conditions of the delay I mean
the the the train company only measures
the delay like they get punished by
Regulators if there's a delay of more
than three hours etc etc but for the
passenger there's all the difference in
the world between I'm sitting in Comfort
with power and I can work and I know
what's going on versus I'm standing I'm
I'm stressed I have no idea no one's
telling me anything but to the to the
train company the laser delay it doesn't
make any difference yeah I think uh it's
the difference between being stuck in
the departure lounge with no idea of
when the plane's going to arrive or
whether you're going to take off if
you're on the tarmac with no idea of
when you're going to take off or on the
tarmac with that countdown it's the same
reason the the reason that Uber was
revolutionary wasn't because oh you can
call a cab from anywhere and it's a
single app that works pretty much across
the entire world but it was the
countdown it was knowing exactly how
long it's going to be until your taxi
arrives I had said and and it being
reasonably accurate because of course
some of that is cheap talk but you're
like oh yeah this is basically correct
Sam Tatum who is the head of ogilvy's
Behavioral Science unit I think was on
the show a couple of weeks ago and he
was one of the guys that contributed to
the Heathrow
complaint reduction thing for security
did you ever look at Rory's stuff that
he did with that
I no I'm not familiar with it I can
imagine the kind of thing but tell me
more so you've got anybody that's been
to Heathrow knows especially if you're
going internally especially terminal
five you just get backed up there's huge
volumes of people flying in from all
over the place to then go
internationally or perhaps the reverse
coming internationally to then go
domestically and uh they were getting
tons of complaints and they needed to
fix it and classically like Engineers do
they looked at it like an engineering
problem okay so how can we fit more of
the scanners within this particular time
can we train the staff in a different
way so that they can speed people up but
the ways that we can prepare the humans
so that their bags are better done in
advance it was a operations logistical
problem and before they decided to
invest probably hundreds of millions of
dollars into trying to fix this problem
Rory and his guy said let's just try a
behavioral change a psychological trick
before we do that and the same way that
they do at Disney World they put 50
minute wait from here 40 minute wait
from here 30 minute wait from here just
signs all the way along and complaints
just went through the floor because it's
not necessarily about the length of time
of the wait although that is a an
inconvenience it's about knowing how
long the weight is going to be it's
setting the expectation am I going to
miss my plane or am I not going to miss
my plane it's fundamentally the plane is
going to take off when it takes takes
off like and if I'm on it it's not it
doesn't really matter how long I waited
for security and if I'm not on it then
it makes all the difference
um it's surprising how difficult this is
but Rory's Rory is terrific at noticing
these kind of things
um but I want can I can I offer a
challenge to something you said oh two
three minutes ago before we we started
riffing on travel delays you were
talking about skin in the game and how
important skin in the game is uh and of
course that's true and there's lots of
good work written on it but you can
overdo the skin in the game so one of
the cautionary tales podcasts one of the
very first ones is called buried by the
Wall Street Crash so for people who
don't know the cautionary tales podcast
it's basically about half an hour I tell
a story quite a rich story of something
going wrong we've got actors we've got
music and something goes wrong and then
the social science in what went wrong
comes out and this particular story is
about these two great economists John
Maynard Keynes everyone's heard of John
Maynard Keynes Irving Fisher less
well-known
and both of them making this
catastrophic
failed forecast and missing the Wall
Street crash of 1929 which wiped 89 off
the value of shares it was huge just
devastating
and I don't want to give too many
spoilers but one of the they ended up in
a very different place having made the
same mistake they had totally different
Fates
and what doomed the guy who was doomed
was that he had so much skin in the game
and he had so much that he could not he
was just completely invested he could no
longer think clearly he was completely
backed into a corner whereas the guy who
did much better
uh was able to basically say oh yeah
I've lost some money but it's no big
deal I haven't lost my reputation I'll
be fine and so yeah skin in the game is
important
it's a good thing but you can have too
much of a good thing overcooking
anything at the moment is something that
I've been thinking about a lot so
a lot of advice online in the personal
development world for a good example
would be the classic Jordan Peterson
line if you know take responsibility and
and you need to to do so
that works in maybe on average perhaps
on average right now in 2022 most people
or more people need to to take
responsibility I have a group of friends
who are pathological responsibility
takers they are the sort of people that
will take responsibility for something
that wasn't even Theirs to take
responsibility for and what you see is
some really interesting extreme examples
that basically you're optimizing to try
and get people into somewhere that's
like a nice gentle meme in the middle of
the bell curve trying to take people out
of the extreme of you have no skin in
the game at all why would you be
invested in this thing it's cheap
signals but you're also not necessarily
optimizing with that advice for the
people that are at the top end that have
99.9 of their net worth tied up in
crypto for instance like how are you
ever going to be anti-crypto how are you
ever going to be able to have an
unbiased opinion of the crypto Market at
the moment another thing I saw you do a
blog post about what people keep getting
wrong about inflation and that's I mean
inflation must be
perhaps a contender for word of the Year
2022 so what what should we understand
about inflation and what do people keep
getting wrong about it
people think of inflation as prices
going up
uh and and indeed it's measured by CPI
consumer prices index which measures
prices going up and journalists very
good journalists who who know what
they're talking about will talk about oh
CPI was 10 that means inflation is 10
prices went up 10 I mean
and it's not wrong but it's missing a
really really important Insight which is
your classical pure textbook inflation
is basically everything the price of
everything going up
by roughly the same amount including
your wages so the price of your labor is
also going up
so basically nothing is really getting
any more expensive in real terms because
the price in the store went up by 10 and
your salary went up by 10 and kind of
the problem is it's all a bit confusing
um here's another form of inflation
which I would say is not really
inflation at all but it's still going to
come out in the price indices and that's
um Vladimir Putin turned off the Taps
for the global Energy System the price
of food went through the roof the price
of natural gas went through the roof the
price of oil went through the roof and
we spend a lot of money on food and
natural gas and oil especially in Europe
uh and so that went you know absolutely
skyrocketed and so on average
prices have gone up by 10 but the prices
of a lot of stuff haven't gone up by 10
and importantly your salary didn't go up
by 10 your take-home pay didn't go up by
10 so that's a relative price change and
in many ways that's much worse than
inflation because you're actually poorer
it's the stuff you want to buy the stuff
you need to buy is more expensive now
having explained that difference you
might say well sure why why does that
matter well it matters because
um the way a central bank should respond
to that is totally different I mean the
way your Central Bank should respond to
the price of everything is going up
about the same including wages is well
that's a problem you need to sit on that
quite hard raise interest rates high but
the price of energy goes through the
roof because there's a war
that's not something the Central Bank
should really be trying to deal with at
all and what makes the current situation
difficult is we've got a mix of both and
central banks are trying to figure out
which of these two types of inflation
to respond to
um and when I wrote that piece which
again was a financial times column two
of the best economists in the financial
times I showed it to them and said what
do you think and they said you're
absolutely right of course but I just
had one more thing and the just one more
thing they wanted to add was two two
pieces of sort of policy advice that
completely contradicted each other
because one of them thought central
banks should start raising interest
rates and the other thought that central
banks weren't raising interest rates
nearly enough and you know and they're
they're really really smart guys that's
the mess we're in and that's why you
know the the problem that central banks
face and the problem we're all going to
face is is not a straightforward one
even the experts don't agree
no and there's a lot of talk about how
there was this famous line in the brexit
referendum in the UK that people have
had enough of experts there's a lot of
anti-expert talk
um and then there's this sort of the
pendulum swing so now people are saying
well you're an idiot you should listen
to The Experts and the truth is well the
experts probably know more than you and
me about whatever it is that they're
expert in
but knowing more having more expertise
having more experience having more
training doesn't guarantee that you get
it right so you want to listen to The
Experts but you don't want to make the
mistake of thinking the experts are
infallible and as as you were saying you
can overcook anything you can overcook
the skepticism of the experts
you can overcook the the faith of the
experts
um which is why this whole game of
trying to understand the world and think
clearly is it is an endless project
you've got a quote that says
indiscriminate doubt is at least as
dangerous as indiscriminate belief
that must be very similar
yeah so my that is a point I made in my
most recent book which is called the
data detective in the US and it's called
how to make the world add up in the UK
and it's a book about how to think
clearly about the world
but in particular how to use numbers how
to use data to think clearly about the
world and the point I observed is I
found that people were falling into a
trap when it came to anything involving
statistics there was a reflexive
skepticism or like lies down lies and
statistics or you can prove anything
with Statistics or this famous book how
to lie with Statistics and just this
idea that you seem kind of really clever
if you say oh well yeah you can prove
anything with it with Statistics but if
you're basically just rejecting
everything on low grounds that it's got
statistics in well that's not smart
either
and so the challenge is to be
discriminating in what you doubt and
what you believe
um but all too often we just let our
emotions lead us astray and we just pay
you know we believe whatever we want to
believe we disbelieve whatever we want
to to disbelieve but when it's framed
too much as oh people will believe
anything and they should be more
skeptical I'm not so sure about that I
mean you think about the um think about
Q Anon what's going on with Q Anon I
mean are these people
who believe anything or these people who
doubt everything who are skeptical of
everything and every source of authority
you can frame it either way that's an
interesting horseshoe that I hadn't
thought of yes the fact that they seem
to net out in a very similar sort of
position the people I did a conversation
with Peter Thiel a little while ago and
he gave this great example of um climate
skepticists and climate optimists uh net
out at the same position that the people
that say we're going to be absolutely
fine with technology it's going to come
down the pike and everything will be
sweet just hold on and the people that
say we're locked into this terrible
future both of them net out at the same
position which is we don't do anything
right now and the way that they get to
that is different and the Futures that
they Envision are also very different
but they net out at the same position I
think um
the reflexive heterodoxy or reflexive
contrarianism is a very easy way for
people to seem smart and that to me
seems to be the primary
seductive quality that taking that on
has that I mean is that what your
position is as well would you think that
mostly what people are doing is looking
cool by being a cynic I think that
that's definitely part of it I think
that uh smackdowns work on social media
if you're calling somebody an idiot that
works a lot better than saying that
somebody somebody's great so they
they're more likely to go viral they're
more like to get purchased but another
thing that's driving this push towards
excessive skepticism the sort of toxic
cynicism it's just that it's it's
generally easier to think of negative
arguments than positive arguments so
there's a discuss some of the evidence
for this early on in my book the data
detective of how to make the world add
up
um where
um psychologists ask people to reason to
produce arguments about a politically
contentious issue I think it was um
capital punishment at the time it was
the the work was done in the 1990s and
as you would expect people find it much
easier to to generate arguments
on their side or or against the side
that they oppose that's not a surprise
but the arguments that were easiest to
generate were arguments attacking the
opposing belief if you ask people to to
come up with reasons why the other side
is stupid they can do that there's so
many arguments they find it incredibly
um easy to do that that those arguments
just flow really really freely people
also find it easy to come up with
positive Arguments for their own side
but not it's not as easy so there's that
the power of negativity I think is
really fundamental there why do you
think it is that it's so much easier for
people to come up with dunks on the
other side than Arguments for their own
side
I'm not sure I mean it may just be
there's more ways to be wrong than to be
right yeah
um yeah but but yeah I'm not absolutely
sure it's an interesting question yeah I
uh I think that certainly the
credentials that you get on Twitter come
from dunking right Twitter's just a
donkey Pawn Fest for the most part very
rarely do you see there's something uh
interesting I noticed online if somebody
crosses a line with
um the type of language that they're
using the insults that they draw
whatever it might be I haven't seen in
as long as I can remember on Twitter
someone breaking the fourth wall of the
argument and saying you've gone too far
that's out of order that's unacceptable
no one ever seems to say that they want
to continue playing this sort of dry
side eye satirical I don't care about
you can't affect me bro type debate
that's the game of tennis that appears
to be being played it's very rarely whoa
whoa whoa hang on hang on hang on
hanging you're not allowed to say that
that's too much because that would
indicate that they'd actually finally
got to you even if they perhaps had but
people will put up this front so you
have public uh
so you have public self-deception which
is probably reflecting internal
self-deception as well but that person
may very well go away and spend the rest
of the evening stewing over what their
detractor online just accuse them of
yeah and and social media are built for
engagement and engagement is driven a
lot by emotions and often it's the
negative emotions not always I mean cat
videos that's that's positive emotions
but a lot of it is driven by negative
emotions I'm I'm quite struck by the
fact I've got nearly 200 000 followers
on Twitter I never get any retweets no
one ever no one ever engages with
anything I post because I'm I mean maybe
I'm boring but I like to think that's
because I'm calm I just sort of you know
say reasonable things and people you
know that people might like it people
might follow me
but they don't retweet that stuff and
the few tweets I've had that have gone
viral are often something like oh it's a
direct quote of a former government
Minister admitting that the government
that she just left is completely
ridiculous or something like that and
then that's something that people can
really get into oh finally this you know
these politicians have admitted what
Hypocrites they are whatever
hundreds thousands of retweets but um
you know that's rare because I'm not I'm
not really interested in in playing that
game and the statistician Andrew gellman
though he makes an interesting point so
I think in a longer form like blogging
for example
there's more of a bias towards excessive
positivity
so there's no harm in writing a blog
post about other people's ideas and
basically just saying hey they're great
these ideas are great yeah that's fine
there's no cost to that no one's going
to complain about that if on the other
hand you write a blog post uh or you
know on a long social media post on
Facebook or medium whatever sub stack
whatever the the format is if you write
something
taking somebody down
um
there are consequence consequences for
that you've got to get your facts right
otherwise you could get sued for example
no one cares if you got your facts right
if you're just being friendly to
everyone
so yeah it's an interesting observation
that the bias towards positivity or
negativity um
depends on the the scale of the media
and the type of the media and actually
it's related to a point I make in in my
latest book
about how the scale of news this the
time scale of news relates to the kind
of news stories we pay attention to so
if you're if you're checking the news
hour by hour it's got to be gossip
Market moves
um stuff blowing up
um if you look at the news once a year
you can actually pick up totally
different sorts of events and if you
were to look at the news once every 10
years you could actually start to track
stuff that really means something
important like the decline in
um childhood mortality or the increase
in global temperatures uh impossible to
track these on a daily or weekly basis
but 10 years 25 years you can see them
yeah do not confuse the noise for the
signal I think and that's what
everybody's doing another really
terrifying Insight that David perel came
up with is that almost all of the
content that we consume will have been
created in the last 24 hours you know
there's entire social media platforms
that are dedicated to producing and
Publishing content that expires after 24
hours the only way that you can consume
it and for anyone that knows what the
Lindy effect is the they are platforms
that are designed to be anti-lindy that
there is literally no way that it gets
to stick about
um thinking about the
concern that people have over
[Music]
relying on statistics that sort of
reflexive heterodoxy I understand coming
out of the back of a period where many
experts
said things and then went back on saying
things and then did a w turn and then
kept on going again
I I
I wonder whether it's a British thing
but I think we're kind of perennially
orderly and the respect of authority uh
seems to be a little bit better in the
UK maybe we don't have that Rebel spirit
that the US does and maybe Australia as
well
but even for me I you know I've come out
the other side of the last two years
with a very different view of experts
and expertise and the people in power
and I think it for me it seemed very
much like a mask off moment that it's
the same degree of
idiocy all the way up and that's not a
bad thing it's ADC all the way down as
well all the way down to me but
realizing the humanness and just how
flawed the people that are given
positions of
um Prestige power expertise
um I I think that's going to be very
very difficult to regrow and I wonder
whether it can ever be done uh at least
in the sort of medium-term future I
think I'm not sure that it can I think
one of the interesting things is that uh
we tend to
want to take an expert in one field and
ask them to opine in other fields and it
can very difficult both for us and for
the experts to realize they've they've
strayed outside their area of expertise
so for example uh in the pandemic you
might have somebody with really deep
expertise in
um tracking virus variants and
understanding mutations and what impact
those mutations might have and then you
then you might say
um well uh you know should we have
another lockdown which actually
immediately gets you into questions of
compliance would people accept another
lockdown how would they behave
um epidemiology how would it spread if
there was another lockdown if if you
sort of moved from it's and it seems
like oh this is an expert in covid
therefore I should ask them a question
about covid but actually no they were
expert an expert in
um viral mutations and now you're asking
them about Behavioral Science in fact
um but which is ridiculous but it
doesn't seem ridiculous and I think even
to most experts it wouldn't seem
ridiculous because they do know
something wouldn't seem ridiculous to
ask them to speculate I mean I I
interviewed um a British statistician
called David spiegelholter
many times he's kind of a National
Treasure here in the UK Professor sir
David spiegelholter former president of
the royal statistical society and he's
terrific but he's one of the few experts
I encountered who would you know wax
lyrical with with great confidence about
something and then you'd ask him a
question and say oh I don't know
anything about that and that's it was
striking because it's so unusual
for people to to say that not a clue ask
me another question
um but I think it's because he's so good
he's such a great communicator and he's
got that confidence
to say what he knows and then to shut up
when he thinks he doesn't know anything
I mean he still gets things wrong we all
get things wrong but it's a good start
it's a signal of
trustworthiness I think and honesty it's
actually something that people could
hack
um but I wonder whether ego defeats
desire to manipulate when it comes to
this that people can't get their own
egos out of the way that the opportunity
to pretend that they don't have a
particular opinion on something that
they maybe don't actually know anything
about is
pushed to one side in place of the
opportunity to
proliferate to propagate their ideas
about the fact that they could or should
be this polymath of solutions well think
about the media ecosystem as well if
you're uh say a radio producer you want
to get an expert on
let's talk about kobit or anything else
the economy whatever it is
um you don't want someone who you ask
them a question and they give you an
answer and then you ask them a second
question and they say I don't know I
don't know about anything about any of
that stuff
I mean of course you could go super deep
into their area of expertise but but you
know like well yeah I mean Good Morning
Britain I often want that but yes Good
Morning Britain doesn't want that the
most mainstream Outlets don't want that
for good reason right that's that's not
what not what most
um consumers of information one title
give me a broad overview
um but that yeah then you have you
select into the very few people who are
actually capable of giving that broader
overview or the large number of people
who are happy to you know go on TV and
and just Bluff it I really like the term
toxic cynicism I think that it's a
wonderful way to package up the
current milieu that you really see
online the fact that it is really
excessive skepticism applied across
everything
apart from things that you have a prior
that you want it to be true
[Music]
previously people would have already had
biases around whatever motivated
reasoning they've got but I'm not
convinced that their degree of
skepticism or cynicism about everything
else would be quite as tuned up as it
has been so what you have now is
an even greater bias that functionally
and even greater bias toward the things
that people want to believe and an even
greater cynicism against the things that
they don't want to believe
yeah and it's reinforced by all of the
things we're very familiar with the echo
chamber effects the political tribalism
and so on I'm sure things that I'm sure
you've discussed many times on the
podcast but yeah it it it doesn't help
it doesn't help at all I mean when I
when I think about why
why we get things wrong why we sort of
make mistakes when we're consuming
information in it from social media or
media I mean fundamentally I think there
are there are three different things
happening and we
and we've paid different different
amounts of attention to them so the
first the most logical is like oh we get
stuff wrong because we don't know enough
so it's kind of incompetence you don't
have the expertise you don't have the
skills you need more training more
information you need to learn more about
statistics or
more about the history of
Ukraine or more about whatever and
that's fine that information deficit
model is obviously important
um the second thing that's going wrong
is these Echo Chambers it's motivated
reasoning I want to reach a particular
conclusion
um and that's incredibly important
that's why I one of the first chapters
in
my book which is also one of my
cautionary tales is all about this great
art critic falling for this
terrible fraud I mean a really terrible
forgery that he should never have
fallen for and my point is this guy knew
more about Vermeer as it was a Vermeer
this guy knew well it wasn't a Vermeer I
should say this guy knew more about
Vermeer than anybody in the world you
couldn't have given him any more
information you couldn't have given him
any more skill he still made the mistake
he made the mistake because he was just
so desperate to believe so that's his
second thing you've got lack of skill
you've got the motivated reasoning the
the desperation to believe then there's
a third thing I think we often miss
which is we're just not really paying
attention
now you're scrolling through on a small
screen and you know it's 144 characters
and he's you know it's so easily just
read something and you think you read
something but actually you read
something else or
um
you know you didn't stop to think for a
moment is that actually true could that
be true
um it's and it's amazing and in all
three cases
uh we've got this we've also got a meta
problem which is a lack of awareness so
the famous done in Kruger effect
unskilled and we don't know we're
unskilled but you've also got motivated
reasoning and the I'm not biased bias
because think about it if you thought
you were biased
you you wouldn't be biased right I mean
obviously you think you're occupying a
reasonable
position on the Spectrum right otherwise
if you thought it was an unreasonable
position you'd move your position and
then of course the brain's incredibly
good at creating these illusions that we
really are paying attention that you you
really can drive and look at your phone
at the same time you really can read the
paper and listen to a podcast at the
same time and and of course you you
can't
um so we make these three mistakes and
we also make these meta mistakes where
we convince ourselves that actually this
stuff doesn't really apply to us I
suppose as well the
fact that we need to deceive other
people the easiest way to deceive other
people is to believe the deception
ourselves
right the fact that if it is and this is
an Adaptive quality in fact I remember
seeing something about one of the
justifications or one of the reasons
that was put forward as to why humans
have got theory of mind and
Consciousness at all is that it allows
us to be able to model what other people
might think and therefore be able to put
our ideas forward in a way which would
create the kind of outcome that it is
that we want because we're socially so
complex there was a story that you had
Apollo Robbins the world's most famous
theatrical pickpocket says yeah the
things right in front of us are often
the hardest to see the things you look
at every day that you're blinded to what
was the similarity between Magic and
misinformation
yeah well it is partly this fact of
believing firmly you've got this
incredibly powerful belief that you are
noticing things that you are paying
attention and you're not so Apollo
Robbins his Ted Talk is fantastic it's
only nine minutes uh I won't spoil it
you should just watch it
it's an absolute master class in
storytelling as well as you know he's an
amazing pickpocket but he's just lifting
stuff he'll say oh
just just check your pocket have I got
your wallet and and while he checks the
the pocket he takes his watch and then
he says Ah
now you've noticed I've got your watch
and then it suddenly reaches for his
watch and then Polly Robbins takes takes
the wallet out of his pocket because
he's looking at his watch and you think
oh I can pay attention to my wallet and
my watch at the same time like you think
you know I am my my senses are
monitoring them both but they're not
you've just got this illusion that they
are and that's what the pickpocket
exploits and the same thing is true
um for information uh on on the media
social media so a fantastic little study
done by if I remember rightly David Rand
at MIT and Gord pennycook at uh Regina
University in in Canada
where they what they did was they um
asked people
uh some people they showed them a bunch
of headlines some of which were fake
news and said uh you know would you
retweet this or not and basically people
would retweet a lot of fake news that
was was on their side
so like if you're a trump supporter and
there's some fake news about Biden being
an idiot you'll you'll tweet it if
you're a Democrat and you see some fake
news that says Trump's done something
ridiculous
you know you'll retweet that so that's
not surprising what's surprising about
this study is
um
they in when if they instead just ask
people can you tell me whether you think
this headline is true or not
they were actually very good at figuring
out oh that actually no there's no way
Trump is going to deport Melania that's
not actually going to happen it's a
delicious headline I'd like to retweet
it but it's obviously not true so if you
ask people instead of will you retweet
it is it true
they can figure out the difference
between truth and falsehood if you say
if you ask them well do you think it's
important to retweet only stuff that's
true people will say yeah it is
important I don't want to retweet
misinformation I only want to retweet
stuff that's true so you go well this is
this is weird people retweet fake news
people can spot fake news people say
it's wrong to retweet fake news and I
wouldn't do it so what's going on and
the answer is they're just not paying
attention and so the final kicker to
this study is when random pennycook ask
people to show them a headline and say
and this is done they did it in the lab
but they also did it in the Wild on
Twitter they show people a headline and
they say
um do you think this headline is true or
not and you know people will evaluate it
and then they just watch their behavior
for the next 48 hours and they are less
likely to retweet untrue claims because
you ask them wants to stop and think
about it
and having stopped and think about it
you're just in a different frame of mind
it's like oh I should probably think
about whether stuff's true or not and it
lasts 48 hours it's incredible and that
just shows you know we're just not we're
not paying attention
we think we would naturally
evaluate the truth of every claim we see
on Twitter or Facebook or whatever that
we just do it and if we get it wrong
it's because we're not smart enough or
because we're we're biased but often we
don't we don't notice that something's
true or false because it never occurs to
us to spend a second's energy on
evaluating the claim and so we don't I
wonder whether revealed and stated
preferences Clash up against each other
a little bit here I think a lot of
people when asked do you think that you
should be retweeting things which are
only proven to be true or obvious satire
yeah yes but if you see something which
is advantageous to your particular side
you're gonna let that one slide of
course you are you think well you know
this time may not be true I don't need
to check too much but it's pretty pretty
fortunate for whatever my point of view
is
and I I mean I agree but that's why it's
so important to have done the experiment
where they tested the impact of just
asking people to evaluate one
statement for truth and then we're able
to observe in the wild you know on
social media that it changed people's
behavior so yeah I'm sure people
exaggerate how important it is to them
only to retweet the truth but you can by
just asking them to think about it for a
second just for a second you can change
their behavior over the course of of the
next couple of days
so what we've talked about so far has
been
logic rationality understanding of
cognitive biases motivated reasoning and
stuff like that
you also say that economists should get
more in touch with their feelings and
I'm very interested in the limits of the
usefulness of a rational approach what
role does intuition have if any in the
modern world and stuff like that so what
are your thoughts there so I've changed
my mind over over the years so as a as
an economist as a young Economist I was
taught rational Choice Theory and you
know this is a good way to understand
people's decision making and of course
people aren't always rational all the
time but it's a great way of it's a
great starting point and in fact I wrote
a whole book called the logic of life
which is all about the different ways in
which rational Choice Theory could be
used to understand things like
addiction and
discrimination crime all kinds of things
that don't seem to have any logic
they're just they're just you know human
weakness or their evil things and some
of them are evil things but they're evil
things with a logic behind them
um
I wouldn't have I wouldn't write that
book today because I'm much more
interested now in the psychology of
things in what's you know now known as
behavioral economics so taking into
account emotions taking into account our
cognitive limitations
alongside rational Choice actually I
think the two together are quite
powerful because if you've got a good
grounding in rational Choice Theory you
have a good sense of what the optimal
decision is at least under certain
conditions you need enough information
enough data
um and if you've got a good ground in
behavioral economics
and in Psychology you've got a good
sense of what it is that's going to stop
you from making that's what's going to
mediate it what's going to stop you from
being that optimal decision maker yeah
and I mean this is why and it comes into
not just decision making but also the
way we process information so this is
why the the opening of my latest book
instead of teaching you some statistical
trick or talking about correlation or
anything like that I say look the first
thing you have to do is observe your
emotional response and you're reading a
headline you're reading an article
looking at something on on social media
before you start calculating or
evaluating or looking for sources or any
of that first of all just say how does
that make me feel
am I am I angry does it make me feel
Vindicated does it make me feel scared
whatever it is
what's that emotion and then just and
then go and have another look look at
the claim again having observed your own
emotion it's it's going to look
different and I'm not saying don't feel
emotions don't feel angry you know don't
feel happy
it's obviously it's legitimate to have
emotions
but you know you should notice that
you're having that emotional reaction
before you go back
and try to engage your powers of logic
because they're they're not they're not
friendly to each other it's best to try
and keep them a bit separate so yeah
understanding emotion is incredibly
important I wonder it seems to me to be
a common trajectory Russ Roberts from
econ talk was on the show a little while
ago in his new book Wild problems is
literally all about this it's the limits
outside of uh economic theory and why
you need to have something else that you
could call Intuition or good instinct or
whatever and uh there's I I find it
fascinating to look at people that have
spent a long time in a particular
industry and where they get to was the
trajectory starts to to Really sort of
uh accumulate a ton of experience and it
seems like everyone's zeroing in on this
you know it's the same way as looking at
your grandparents for how to live a good
life as the grandparents towards the end
of it they're you know not really
chasing the status so much anymore
they're not playing with keeping up with
the Joneses they're not picking fights
with people for no apparent reason
they're just
settling into something that's a little
bit more simple and I think that yet uh
you and Russ as um flag waving Economist
ambassadors for someone integrating a
little bit more
felt sense holistically seems like a a
good signal to me yeah well it's very
flattering to be compared to Russ he's
got an amazing podcast and he's he's got
a lot of experience and his I mean he's
coming in from a slightly different
angle to me but I think it's a very it's
a very important angle which is he's
he's just super skeptical about our
ability to know anything to understand
any system it's like it's always more
complicated than you think
um I have a a little bit more faith in
our ability to comprehend the world than
Russ does uh but I think it's a really
useful
check
to say do we do you really think you
understand this do you really think
we've we can fix this now with with
enough data
um because that's a very tempting path
and it's very important to have someone
like Russ just whispering in your ear
are you sure
you sure you really understand
what was that story about Arthur Conan
Doyle and the fairies
I I love it I love that story it's um
it's it's one of the cautionary tales
and it it's a it's quite a famous story
although as with many of the cautionary
tales you've heard you might have heard
some of the story
but you don't you don't know all the
details and the details are so
delightful but it's all about cone and
oil
uh the the creator of Sherlock Holmes
one of the most famous men in the
British Empire
hearing that two little girls from
Yorkshire near Bradford
have taken photographs of fairies at the
bottom of the garden and he heard about
this I think in 1920 the first
photograph was actually taken in 1916 if
I remember rightly
um and he wrote a whole book
at the coming of the fairies and he said
well obviously this could be a hoax
um and you be the judge but I think more
likely it is in the epoch making
Discovery
you know spoiler it was not an important
making Discovery it was a hoax I was
just so fascinated by both by how
Doyle convinced himself of this thing
that is transparently ludicrous
but also
what the girls were thinking
what how what makes two little girls
perpetrate such a hoax and at what point
did they think oh
this has all got much bigger than we
ever intended and so both sides of that
story are rather beautiful
it's something to see a author that
created a character who is supposed to
pay attention to the little things and
be aware of his cognitive biases fall
prey to two little girls how did they
make the photo well this is one of the
interesting things that this whole thing
was was deconstructed much much later by
the British Journal of Photography which
for decades had said this is ridiculous
we're not going to descend and in the
end I thought all right fine we'll look
at this and they the editor of the
British general photography published
like a 10 10
issue expose it's about 80 pages long in
total it's incredible and there are I
think there are five photos there are
four different methods of fakery and
that's one of the things that did
confuse people because if you're looking
for like what is the one thing they did
to make these photos there is no one
thing you you will never find it
um and funnily enough that links back to
that we were talking about stage magic
one one of the ways in which really good
stage magicians will fool people and
they've and it helps them to fool other
magicians is they'll do the same trick
over and over again
you say people say oh you should never
perform the same trick twice but they do
they'll perform the same trick over and
over again but each time there's a
different method
to achieve the same effect
so we know one time it's that you've
palmed the coin another time it's kind
of you're doing this you're doing that
you're using a dummy and so somebody
who's trying to get a sense of like oh
how are they doing that oh I think he
might have done that and then they'll
watch the next time you do it and you
you do it in a different way and they're
just more confused than ever and so this
is this is the the problem that that
Conan Doyle had so one of the
one of the paintings with one of the
photographs was actually heavily
post-processed by an expert so it was
basically photoshopped
um you physically painted over the
negative and that was supposed to be to
enhance it for displayer to lecture
another one was a double exposure
um which is not surprising given one of
the girls was actually a little girl
she's 17 years old and she woke she
worked in a photo studio doing double
exposures all day I'm like not really
that surprising she could do that
another one was just um
uh you know paper cutouts and they're
just you know just took a photograph of
a little girl sitting next to a paper
cut out and you know the photos
two-dimensional so you
you can't tell it's paper cut out
um so these different methods and he
just went through these extraordinary
contortions to convince himself that it
that it must be true and he he wasn't
just the creator of Sherlock Holmes
because he was that two other things he
had intervened
um in in a kind of in the serial of you
know the serial podcast you know this
whole thing he was involved in that the
Edwardian equivalent of cereal where
there was somebody who'd been convicted
of this crime and Conan Doyle was
convinced he was innocent and it
assembled this amazing amount of
evidence and got him off and I think
probably rightly
um so he was could be completely
forensic the other thing if you want to
guess where Conan Doyle's first ever
work was published
you'll never guess no idea British
Journal of Photography he was actually
an expert photographer he knew loads
about photography and so that was all
just you think well how could he be
fooled and it and it was just oh well I
know so much about photography I know
how hard photography is
these little girls can't possibly have
have pulled off trick photography
because I know how hard trick
photography is so
it's something we see over and over
again is expertise is an advantage if
you're thinking clearly and you're not
emotional but once you're emotionally
engaged expertise can be in an active
disadvantage it can actively drag you
down because you create more reasons
even if there's various reasons to
believe whatever it is you're you're
wanting to believe one of my friends
Gwenda Bogle has this fantastic Insight
where he says when intelligent people
affiliate themselves to ideology their
intellect ceases to guard against
wishful thinking and instead begins to
fortify it causing them to inadvertently
Mastermind their own delusion and to
very cleverly become stupid
Conan Doyle is an example and so was
Abraham radius the art critic we were
talking about he he saw things in this
fake Vermeer
that I would never see that most people
would never see incredibly sophisticated
reasons to believe that it was genuine
and there was one big reason to think it
wasn't genuine which is it didn't look
anything like anything for me it had
ever painted
um but he was willing to look past all
of that because he could see all these
subtleties and um yeah expertise I'm in
favor but it can be misused like
anything else tell me about what you
learned to do with the invention of the
bicycle because one of my friends George
Mack
sent me a study years ago that explained
the efficiency the movement efficiency
of different animals in the animal
kingdom and it's some particular number
whatever it is energy versus distance or
something like that and then he adds in
they add in a human on a bicycle and a
human on a bicycle is a factor of 10
better than the the best moving
Albatross or whatever Marlin or whatever
it is so what did you learn about the
the bicycle what did I learn about the
basket I mean there's so many different
things that I studied the bicycle for
another book of mine called 50 things
that made the modern economy which also
is a podcast series and I just explored
different inventions and one of the
Delights of the bicycle uh was just the
way that it reshaped Society now when
when people were ready the bike was
quite a long time in gestation
uh but when people were ready it just
turned everything on its head uh so it
was it was a real Force for the
emancipation of women
um who could cycle around without a
chaperone and there were various
campaigners who said oh you know this is
going to lead to fornication and
prostitution laboratory on the back of a
bicycle but
um and there's a there's a wonderful
there's a um a kind of tabloid news
headline of the day which which is about
a woman I think it was Amalia Allen if I
remember her name rightly and it was
Front Page News because she'd Gone Gone
bicycling in trousers and so this
headline was she wore trousers and uh
she's divorced lady cycling around in
trousers but the interesting thing was
like everyone was excited about this
divorced lady in trousers no one was
worried about the bicycling so it's
incredible
uh freedom and there was one um one of
the leading uh women's rights
campaigners and I'm blanking on her name
who was asked who who was basically
campaigning for universal suffrage and
so on throughout the 19th century and I
think died in about 1920 and she was
asked what what had been the greatest
contributor to women's freedom and she
said the bicycle uh so it these these
inventions whether it's the brick or
whether it's paper or whether it's the
bicycle they they changed the world by
changing us it's not just they solve a
little problem that we had they slot
right into our society and and we just
go on as normal except that one little
thing is easier we've got a better
mousetrap they they work because they
just they create new winners and new
losers and reshape the way we live and
the bicycle is a is a great example of
that I remember learning about when
caffeine was first introduced when
coffee shops first came about because up
until that point during the middle of
the day if a gentleman and his friends
wanted to go and discuss some serious
philosophical or political ideas the
only place that they could go would be
the Tap House or the pub and inevitably
after a few of the only drinks that were
mostly consumed there the conversation
degenerated somewhat whereas as soon as
the introduction of caffeine happened
that actually permitted people to go out
during the day and maybe even not only
have it degrade but improve over time as
they drank a little bit more caffeine
and they were a little bit more alert
and and they were and this is something
I remember reading about Aristotle he
was going to these discussions at a
influential friend's house dinners on an
evening time and he put forward a
suggestion that they replace all of the
cups and the glasses on the tables with
smaller ones he said because it'll make
us think that we're drinking the same
amount but we'll actually drink a little
bit less and that will facilitate it's
going to foster a better conversational
environment the same thing whatever 1500
years later is
stop drinking so much during the day if
you want to have a good Comfort good
conversation I would love to see the
randomized trial on that you know did
that work
um but yeah it I mean it's it's amazing
and there's um there's a related example
which is
Henry Pelham the British prime minister
uh this is 1700s if I if I'm correct if
I remember rightly he changed the tax
regime on T So T was taxed at 100 or
more
uh and so loads of smuggling not much
tea actually drunk and he slashed tax on
tea
and the put the Smugglers out of
business people consumed a lot more tea
tax revenues from tea went up this is
what the current British government is
trying to do but it turns out it's not
as easy as Henry Peller made it look
um so they cut taxes revenues went up
and
um an economist uh Francesca Antman
found that she could track this massive
spike in the consumption of tea because
there'd been this big policy change and
she could actually track it through to
the mortality figures she's got all the
births and deaths and was able to see
the decline in the mortality rate
because people were boiling
their water because that's what you need
to do for tea and then they didn't have
germ Theory they didn't know it was
making the water safer but it was and
you can see it in the death figures
that's very cool I got suggested
complete tangent I got suggested a book
this weekend uh Churchill's Ministry of
ungentlemanly warfare you familiar with
this no I immediately want to read it
though I am going to be harping on about
this for quite a while so
in 1939
before Germany invades Poland there's
murmurings that the wars afoot and the
British government decides that they
need to start up a
secret clandestine Guerrilla arm and
they need to come up with very
innovative ways to disrupt the potential
oncoming Nazi offensive and occupation
so they start to find inventors
criminals
soldiers but they've all got very unique
different skill sets one of them had
created a the Limpet mind it was the
inventor of the Olympic mine and he was
now driving around in a 18-foot High
Caravan complete with four bedrooms and
two bathrooms and hot and cold running
water in the 1930s and they got a hold
of him and they got a hold of this
Scottish guy that had lived under this
incredibly sort of austere environment
and was just the most Reckless guy and
he would go out and womanize on an
evening time and then come in during the
day and he created the first pamphlet of
Guerrilla warfare ever and it was edible
in case they were captured by the enemy
and he timed himself to see how long it
would take to eat it and he said that
with a good sized glass of water a
gentleman could consume the entire
pamphlet in less than two minutes and
just an end it's like a The Avengers but
sort of in the 1930s and gentlemanly and
and it's just it's outstanding so uh
Churchill's Ministry of ungentlemanly
warfare really well written super
beautiful prose really easy super
accessible and I'm in love with it at
the moment it's very good I don't I love
it I have to read it and investigate
cautionary tales I'm always finding
whenever I read anything these days I'm
like just I'm I'm just here for when
something goes terribly wrong and I can
start learning lessons that's that's so
that's the cautionary tales uh caution
Tales mission in life you can justify it
however you want for the podcast there
was a one of the things that he'd done
with the Olympic mind this guy they were
struggling to find a way to create a
Time release mechanism that would
dissolve in water or would reduce down
in water an even time so you could have
a different type of powder that could be
used but the compression of the powder
was the there was varieties in that too
much compression it would never go off
to a little compression and it might
kill the diver that's supposed to set it
and uh this guy was eating uh aniseed
balls
um his daughters dropped him on the
floor because he was always shifting
them off the bench where they needed to
work in his house before they got this
office in in London and he realized that
the aniseed balls almost always seemed
to dissolve in his mouth at the same
speed no matter what he did so they
ended up using aniseed balls as the
detonation triggers for these things but
then they realized that they needed to
keep them dry because if they got
slightly wet during Transportation or
whatever that they didn't that it would
have changed the length of time that the
fuse would have gone for as soon as it
gets in water
so he then realized that a condom was
the exact size and shape to be able to
protect this thing so this is before you
could Amazon anything so they went
around his home town picking up aniseed
balls and condoms and apparently bought
all of the anise balls and condoms in
the local town where he lived and ended
up and they said uh the author just
decides to add a side note saying it is
uh it is unclear whether or not there
was an increase in uh childbirth's uh
nine months later in and around
Guildford or wherever it was that this
guy was from but yeah it's phenomenal
that's I'm I'm pretty confident that
you'll enjoy it I love it I love it on
the subject of an increase in
childbirths and uh cutting taxes which
we were talking about with tea there is
a fantastic study uh of something that
happened in Australia about 15 years ago
where the the government said oh we're
going to give you a baby bonus if you
have a baby 3 000 Australian dollars
um that's about 1500 US Dollars
something like that
um so like it's worth having and they
announced it with six weeks notice so
they announced it in mid-may and was
going to come into effect at the end of
June beginning of July and people said
is that not a bit Reckless I mean are
people not going to try and time their
babies
it to get the the baby bonus and the
Australian shouldn't you have just
announced it with immediate effect and
the Australian government were like oh
no no it's fine it's fine it's fine no
one will do that and the birth rate on
the 1st of July was more than twice the
birth rate on the last day of June like
all those people basically just go just
hold on just hold on and it's amazing
it's amazing you eat your your birth and
indeed your death response to tax
incentives because they found a similar
effect with abolishing inheritance tax
um so yeah people people respond to
incentives this is this is the
your clan the classic Economist in me
rational Choice Theory it does actually
explain a few things my friend's wife is
a school teacher and in her class last
year she had a sweepstakes where all of
the kids she was pregnant sweepstakes up
on the board this is the month that the
new baby is supposed to be born in and
everybody pick a day when do you think
it's going to happen or whatever uh but
she didn't tell them the actual due date
it's like this is the month or whatever
this is the period uh and her least
favorite student the one that she really
hates chose the correct due date uh and
sure enough she was getting closer to
the time that she's supposed to give
birth and her Waters broke on the
evening of that day and she held on to
not give birth to the baby until the
next day to spite this child that she
hated she sounds like a really
inspirational teacher I I really I
thought that that conversation was
phenomenal it was absolutely great there
were many lessons there although I would
have said could you not just have the
baby and then lie about the birthday
perhaps yeah yeah which would be more
more surreptitious but there's a degree
of manipulation and honesty going on
here which is sort of beaut it's a
beautiful dance
um
speaking of taxes and speaking of
children I'd be remissed if I didn't ask
you what do you think about
incentivizing British mothers with tax
deductions to have children I think it
was originally a Hungarian policy if we
can put to one side the person that
actually came up with it or proposed it
or okayed it I thought when I first
heard of that a month ago
I was like surely this is a win but
surely this has got to be a win for
mothers that want to decide to have
children it's going to open up their
Financial Freedom it's going to give
them more time at home it's going to
maximize we're going to the population
collapse and all of the different things
that we need what's the view of an
economist philosopher
so well I mean the two things I would
say our prompt is is first of all
do you have any reason to believe that
um Society wants more or fewer children
than individual
mothers would choose by themselves you
know is there some reason to believe
that they're
they're not taking into account
you know some social cost or social
benefit it's it's not it's not clear
because you can cut it both ways
um the second thing I'd say is we do
already incentivize
children in the sense that
that income support is paid there's a
child benefit paid so if you have
children you do get money until they're
18 years old and to offset the cost of
having them
um I guess the third thing though is if
fundamentally if what you want is more
people
um you could also be more welcoming to
immigrants so you could do both and I
find it interesting that the people
advocating the baby bonuses are
generally not advocating uh Freer
immigration restrictions and I would
have thought that actually when you look
at it logically
but those things are probably pushing in
the same direction certainly something
we've had in in the UK from open borders
with the EU was lots of quite young
people coming by Young I mean like
people in their 20s coming
um working hard paying taxes not really
demanding a lot of benefits because you
know they're young they're working age
um and uh
didn't seem to be very popular uh but
it's not clear to me that that's
actually a worse solution than trying to
incentivize others to have children is
that
I feel like I can't identify I've over
engineered the answer to the question or
dodged I think well it's interesting
it's it's things that I hadn't
considered certainly the immigration
point is one that people would point to
I think that
it it shouldn't be the case that your
population growth is
at the stage where you need to import
other people in order to be able to
supplement it it feels like immigration
should be a bonus on top rather than
something that because if you continue
the clock forward based on the current
trends you would end up with a very
non-british-born British population
although you would have second
generation and third generation and
whatever whatever and everybody is a
hodgepodge of everything I'm sure that
if I looked at my genetic tree that I
would end up being from Ireland or
Scotland or some other place
um I I understand the concern that some
people have about diluting down British
culture by importing too many people
that aren't necessarily immediately a
part of that integration would be great
um being from the northeast of the UK
it's
pretty diverse at least in the schools
and the areas that I was at it was
um
it's an interesting one I I don't know I
I think that the really cool question
around
is the reason that women aren't having
more children because they don't think
that they can afford it basically
um I see in the comments on a lot of
videos that I've done to do with the
mating crisis dating challenges young
people not having sex uh more than 50 of
women for the first time in history
child lost by 30 that wasn't right as it
was the other one that did that study 22
to 45 year old women unmarried and
childless for the first time blah blah
blah
some of the comments from an N of one
completely unrandomized study uh we're
talking about it's very difficult to
bring a child into this world because
it's pretty expensive
um yeah
so just a couple of thoughts then so one
is I mean
it's it's a good question but we're not
the right people to answer it I would
basically two two blokes I don't know if
you've got children I've got three
children but I think my wife probably
knows more about the decisions to have
these children than I do you know we
should probably ask more women uh who
have decided to have children and who
have decided not to have children
um the second point is that
um Daniel Kahneman I think he originally
got this idea from Kurt Lewin great so
um psychologist of the early 20th
century and mid-20th Century Daniel
Kahneman says we often think of the if
you mention the analogy with a car
we want to get the car to move faster
and we're always thinking about rather
than removing debris hitting hitting the
accelerator but yeah take your foot off
the brake so yeah the I think your
instinct is absolutely right before you
say we should pay women more money to
have children we should look around and
go and and figure out why they're not
having children in the first place and
is and is it a problem
or are they having children for are they
not having children for completely
legitimate reasons that actually there's
no you know no reason you'd want to to
that would be their decision that would
be a great study for someone to do to
look at
for a woman for women big chunk of women
nice big sample how many children would
you want to have
how many children do you think you'll
have or perhaps even if you were to take
a
it would be difficult to do it for right
now but you'd certainly be able to look
at maybe the last 20 years women that
were 50s perhaps how many children did
you want to have and how many did you
end up having I mean I how many
different like fertility issues
availability of husbands cycling through
different partners like there's a
million different things that could get
in the way but that would be fascinating
to look at how many children a woman
would want to have and how many she ends
up having and if I remember rightly so I
interviewed for my BBC podcast more or
less I've interviewed Marina adshade a
few times she's uh she's an economist at
British Columbia uh
uh University and she's written a book
called dollars and uh dollars and sex if
I remember rightly
and
she if I I may be misremembering but the
last time we were talking about
fertility but fertility rates
I think she told me that women are in
general having fewer children than they
would like
and that
that is something that would concern me
much more than just looking at a
demographic pyramid and saying well I
don't like them I don't like them upside
down yeah I would be I would be much
more interested in well you know how do
the people who are alive today feel
about the decisions that they're making
and would do they want to make different
decisions if only
they have the money or if only you know
some other obstacle was removed yes I
think
well one of the fascinating things is
that
a woman's desire to have children is
going to be culturally mediated that
doesn't stay static throughout time
either neither do the economic
conditions that she's trying to bring
the child into the world with which is
going to mediate her choice to do that
neither do the availability of potential
partners for her to be able to create
the child with and then raise the child
with so there are a lot of moving Parts
as we go through this but young people
between the age of 18 and 30 are having
three times less sex over the last 10
years that's gone down specifically for
men uh eight percent to 28 it's also
gone up for women as well the amount of
sexlessness and this finishes in 2018. I
can't I need someone to do this study
between 2018 2022 I need to find out
somebody out there tell me how little
sex everybody's having so so talk talk
to Marina adshade see if Marina would be
interviewed she's great she knows way
more about this than I do and uh yeah
should be really interesting uh
interviewee I shall steal her contact
details off you after this look Tim
Harvard ladies and gentlemen Tim very
much appreciate you very much appreciate
your work where should people go if they
want to check out more of the stuff that
you do online so uh cautionary tales
with Tim Harford is the podcast or on
the BBC BBC more or less and my website
is Tim harford.com you read all the
Articles you can find the Twitter links
all that good stuff thanks Tim what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe subscribe
peace
[Music]